l'opération rendez vous aux jardins
reprend du service pour voir fraîchir
mais une grosse centaine de coin de
verdure en bourgogne ouvrent leurs
portes à partir de demain dont le jardin
méconnu de la forteresse de berbères
chatel en saône-et-loire damien louis
tillaye romy aux échecs
la forteresse de berzé le châtel un
édifice médiéval impressionnant mais peu
de gens savent que derrière les trois
murs d'enceinte se trouve de magnifiques
jardins pour la comtesse demi
propriétaire des lieux cet écrin de
verdure est un atout pour son château
chez les chose d'unique
ce n'est jamais pareil suivant la
lumière vous n'avez voyez aujourd'hui un
petit peu avec des nuages c'est donc
c'est ça donne une autre lumière après
ça c'est l'automne c'est doré c'est
superbe
il pourra temps enfin ouf tout re et
nous avons toutes les petites fleurs qui
sortent les narcisses y aller et
personnages enfin des premiers c'est
quelque chose de vivant qui bouge tout
le temps
ce n'est qu'à la fin du 19e siècle que
les enceintes ont été transformés en
jardin avec notamment une vocation
potagères et ici on trouve de tout comme
nous l'expliquent marcel le jardinier il
ya des pommes de terre il ya des des
tomates
il ya des fraisiers iliad asperges 1 il
ya même des plans de bruit
bon ben vous il ya du port ont planté un
il ya des échalotes tout ce qui est plus
qui peut se trouver un emploi dans un
potager quoi autre lieu du château autre
vocation autre style ici on est plus
dans la représentation avec ce jardin à
la française ses strictes aux jardins
français c'est très strict et comme on
peut voir tous les hits et art topiaire
les bruits très strictes on est taillé
au cordeau
ainsi il faut deux paysagistes pendant
deux journées complètes pour tout mettre
en ordre
mais pour peu importe la fatigue
travaillèrent ici c'est un privilège
une fierté personnelle des gens et puis
bon c'est pas à la portée de tout le
monde de pouvoir aussi c'est pas le le
particulière lui même qui peut tailler
des végétaux de cette envergure entre
pierre de cette façon en tout cas pour
ce week-end de promenade au jardin pas
d'inquiétude à avoir
tout sera taillé arrosé biner pour être
admiré